je tiens quand même à dire que dans tout
ce qui s'est passé du côté de la
catalogne
il y avait je m'excuse du mans il y à
une imposture de la part des dirigeants
nationalistes pourquoi il laisse croire
que l'indépendance de la catalogne
aurait pour conséquence que la catalogne
va faire partie immédiatement si elle
est indépendante de l'union européenne
ce qu'il faut ce qui est faux et juncker
l'a rappelé en disant qu'il vous ne
lirez peine et ça va procéder et d'autre
d'un pays car là bas on se comporte
comme si véritablement demain
l'indépendance allait entraîner de
plain-pied l'adhésion à l'union
européenne
c'est faux parce qu'il faudra que la
catalogne sorte de l'union européenne si
elle devient dépendant et pour rentrer
dans l'union européenne il faudra
l'accord unanime de tous les états
membres y compris de l'état espagnol
donc c'est comme dans le bric site il ya
une partie de la campagne menée par les
nationalistes qui est basé sur de
fausses informations
je dirais même sur des mensonges